president truck today echoed calls for
Americans to hunker down and avoid
unnecessary travel well my
administration is recommending that all
Americans including the young and
healthy work to engage in schooling from
home when possible avoid gathering in
groups of more than ten people avoid
discretionary travel and avoid eating
and drinking in bars restaurants and
public food courts while this is a
prudent Public Health move what's the
cost of the economy joining us now
I'm delighted he is with us Steve Forbes
chairman and editor-in-chief of Forbes
media and Jon Katz Matias who is the
odor of Gristedes am I saying that right
space supermarket chain I hope I'm
saying that right Christine how much
economic damage could a nationwide
lockdown do even just two weeks to the
US economy Laura the damage is going to
be substantial and it's going to hurt a
lot of individuals and it's going to put
out of business tens of thousands of
businesses unless something is done not
just small businesses but big ones as
well starting with the airlines that's
why it's essential for the Federal
Reserve to do now what it did 12 years
ago and provide loans through commercial
paper they can set up a facility to
provide money cash to otherwise solvent
businesses to keep them through this
storm on the individual side president
Trump has to push for a suspension of
the payroll tax that'll put to $2,000 or
more in people's pockets between now and
year-end and also something like with
Senator cotton is proposing for middle
and low income people to get a one-time
check the nice thing about these
measures Laura is they end when the
crisis ends instead of this sitting paid
leaving things like that which will
crush small business in the future do
these one-time emergency measures
they're expensive but the stock markets
already lost six trillion dollars in
value do these one-time things and we'll
get through the storm and be prepared
for a recovery later this year yes Steve
I did my angle earlier on the just how
this can't become the new normal every
time a health crisis occurs in another
country and then just wreck our economy
that can't be the new normal we have to
lessons from this going forward about
how we deal with China how we deal with
supply chains how we deal with testing
at airports this mean you can't shut
down the economy again in the fall if
this virus pops back up no and one of
the things that should be done along
those lines in addition especially on
the drug side and there are technologies
now where we can vastly improve the
manufacturing of drugs is in terms of
China and that though those things
should be done but also I think in terms
of the future we need a commission like
we did after Pearl Harbor like we did
after 9/11 why did the CDC be really
botched this thing up we weren't
prepared with tests they knew back in
November December a bad thing was coming
our way and they didn't were they
responded like a bureaucracy more
interested in bureaucratic rules rather
than mobilizing the private sector you
contrast that with South Korea which is
already done each day more tests and
we've done since December and that's an
outrage and that we've got to avoid that
again so he dipped these things in the
bud
we had experience with Ebola of a swine
flu and other epidemics potential
epidemics why did they fail this time we
need to find out to prevent that from
happening again
yeah and D couple from China when it
comes to essential products medicines
and medical supplies we cannot be held
hostage by them soon
yeah well John I want to talk to you
about the food supply we've had enormous
amount of panic on the part of Americans
in wanting to make sure they have enough
food for their families what can you
tell us tonight about that concern of
American families and how they should be
reacting well I think that there's a
shortage of toilet paper of course it's
always a shortage of toilet paper and
there's a shortage of certain Clorox
products and products that are for
cleaning but people are panicking and
it's not about the Fed I don't think the
Fed can solve this problem it's about
giving people hope that there's a
solution out there I mean the Fed has
cut rates to nothing did not help the
Fed
has said said their healer provides 700
billion dollars it didn't help this is
about providing hope to the people and I
think President Trump has done
everything right so far he's done he has
closed the borders which is the right
thing to do and I think Trump is tough
enough that if one of the companies has
a virus vaccine or very close to it
I think he's gonna force it and make it
happen and you know have some blue sky
out there yeah I mean everyone wanted
Trump to be you know as forthright and
and in somber as he was today and as he
was Steve you saw the market go down
even further when he was speaking
because he said it could be July or
August and he didn't mean we're gonna be
in our houses to July or August but he
meant it could the virus could still be
circulating well I think the key thing
now is to have the Fed one make sure
these solvent businesses don't go under
and do what the president's recommended
in terms of a payroll tax so that people
get immediate relief and also reduces
the cost of businesses to keep people
working and so that's when when and so
the president I think should be
emphasizing those things as well as
they're not painting of too rosy a
picture I think will recover from this
sooner as soon as we get those tests out
there and get a real note knowledge of
what the facts are so we can respond
appropriately and laser like instead of
shooting in the dark because we just
don't know yeah we need more information
more facts and that will determine the
future chorus gentlemen thank you so
much great to see you both